hi I'd like to first uh tell you a story
and then go deeper into
the the thoughts I had today about
making this film
I was looking back on life and um
the situation that I got into and being
a motor mechanic and a young guy and you
know
like a brick wall massive hands
um I didn't really care much about
needing aikidos and martial art to look
after myself
um you know egotistical like I would
think most young men
so when I used to go out to clubs or
pumps discos all the
all the things that young people do I
wasn't really bothered it was as if I
felt as I was bigger than the rest I
could handle myself just being big
ignorant really isn't it looking back
but that's what young men do they they
live on their egos
anyhow I was doing Ikea though because
uh I was talked into it
and um I was enjoying it I wasn't really
looking at it as a martial art not one
bit because I was quite happy with what
my hands could do and
you know good strong punches and you
know if anybody hit me
it pretty much didn't disturb me
I was brought up by a very hard father
and lived in the country
where we used to have to he taught me
how to shoot I would send me out to find
meat for the table
I shoot used to shoot pigeons pheasants
we used to catch rabbits with snares and
ferrets if anybody knows what I'm
talking about here
and um
at nights he would be a poacher and
that's where you go across the farmer's
fields and if they're harvesting
potatoes at the time that's what you'd
you'd have perhaps quarter a bag of
potatoes on his shoulders
he tell me perhaps to cut some cabbages
or pick up some swedes and home we would
go and with that
and with the shoe from another day we'd
have a normal
meal
so I'm trying to say that uh I wasn't
really bothered about much of my younger
days and and grew into what manly Hood
and stayed that way I would think until
my mid-30s
you know where I thought I was big and
strong and
I was doing Aikido because I enjoyed it
it was very pleasurable why would I be
worried about handing myself when also
in my life the bullies that picked on
you at school
you know I doubt with them
quite easily
the ones what were hard to to beat with
the real thin skinny worry ones
you seemed to hit them and struggled
with them
in the playground and they just wouldn't
go down
so I'm painting my picture of a bully as
well I suppose and uh
this is what I'm looking back on
and I wanted to say that because in real
situation I'm in real situation where
I've had to
use Aikido
it's been four times
where
one of us would have been in hospital if
not worse
one was in Russia
one was in Czechoslovakia Park
one was in a in a pub in the UK
in the village at Iris living and
working at the time grantchester
and another one was in kefalonia not so
many years ago
the first instance was
someone we were at a bar
and
it was another English person who was
drunk didn't know them
I was in Prague on a
I'd won a competition through selling
the most amount of new cars
and we're in this hotel at the bar many
of us I don't know but
a few a few deep at the bar
and a long mode
and I didn't
say this
black person
close to me or near me it was you know
as far as I would say and it's just
another head or face amongst many
and I was
sort of pushed on my right shoulder
and I turned and this chat was slurring
but saying apologize to him apologize to
him
thing and I'd said something racist
and because I hadn't and hadn't even
noticed
that really anybody was any different
than anybody else because I've never
been like that people are people
anyhow I said I don't know what you're
talking about
and I turned back and I pushed me a bit
harder
and I said look go away I'm not going to
apologize to anybody that I I haven't
said anything to
the next thing was this fist was coming
through the air at my face
and the strange thing was
it was as if it was in slow motion
and I can only contribute this to
training for a few years in aikida at
that time I don't know how many years
but it was a few years
but this fist seemed to be coming
forever and ever
I caught it
and tweaked it and and I didn't realize
what I'd done but
I caught in down the nicchio on the top
part of the
wrist
the pain must have been so
great that it made him pass out and he
lay on the floor
it was quite ironic really because
there was a lot of ladies of the night
in this hotel
and perhaps waiting for customers
and about four or five of them got a
hold of him
found his key in his pocket
and took him away to his room
the next uh
morning that he was bandaged up arm up
bandage around his wrist and he
recognized me what I didn't really
recognize him he recognized me and said
oh yeah can I have a word and that's
when I knew that he was definitely
English
and I said I don't want any trouble and
he said no no I just want to know
what the hell you done to me
two
make me have this much pain and I just
said to him
um there was a martial art I had a nerve
and by the way I hadn't said anything
inappropriate
to the person
and we left out of that